hey what's going on is spilled burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking yoo-hoo what's going
on just checking in on you
how was your Thursday afternoon going Oh
Billy Billy Balu
he left Ireland he left Dublin for
fucksakes and now I'm in I'm in London
I've I flew into a fro yeah
the typical Heathrow experience just I
just don't [ __ ] understand what the
problem is with that goddamn Airport I
hate that [ __ ] Airport I love it
because I'm going to London but I hate
it when I get there I was flying from
Dublin to London which is like flying
from [ __ ] LA to San Francisco
essentially nice easy flight you're on
Southwest there doing stand-up you're
waiting for it to be over
and by the time they finish their
routine they're already landing and
they've begun where they're we're now
landing routine where they imitate
[ __ ] c-3po and [ __ ] Darth Vader
what it what it whatever it is that
those people are trying to do over there
anyways I guess they feel there's a lot
of nervous Flyers over there and for
some reason bad stand-up comedy is the
thing I guess then you're not afraid to
die because you're like well at least if
the plane crashes I don't hear the end
of this routine Oh bill that's no
way--just it's Thursday man it's
supposed to be a happy adventure so
anyways I'm flying from Dublin into a
fro and everything's goes great take off
on time land a little bit early gate is
ready you know but I did the
unforgiveable I checked a bag which I
never do I didn't want to do on this
trip but you know my wife talked me into
it
which I'm actually glad she did once I
get the bag and I unpack
actually have some of my stuff you know
I have some options for a different
outfit sorry so everything goes great
and then you know I get off the plane
I'm staying in there I get the
information oh I don't have to go
through customs because I was already
[ __ ] in Dublin or whatever which I
didn't think was part of the the whole
Great Britain [ __ ] reach I thought I
would think if I was in Northern Ireland
if I felt food from Belfast to London
they'd be like all right I was in the
Republic of Ireland you know I was there
not part of Great Britain are they other
Great Britain was was was England Wales
Scotland and Northern Ireland whatever
maybe because I'm in the European Union
I don't know what the [ __ ] it is but
then I thought they did the brexit thing
but maybe that hasn't happened yet I
don't know all I know is I haven't gone
through I didn't have to go through
customs so I was sacked and I got out of
the [ __ ] stupid carousel thing
whatever the baggage claim and it's
already turned on I'm like you [ __ ]
kidding me and I see three bags come out
then there's a little space a little
space little space I see two bags coming
I'm like holy [ __ ] they're already
unloading it so I stand there for a good
five minutes and it's just those three
bags little space little space little
space then the two bags and then I start
recognizing the bag saying oh these are
just bags that were sitting here you
know five people didn't make it were
sold into human trafficking and they
haven't claimed their bags I don't know
what the [ __ ] happened right or they
went ahead of their flight or their bags
got on and they didn't who the [ __ ]
knows and I was standing there ten
minutes goes by fifteen minutes goes by
twenty minutes goes by the belts on the
same [ __ ] three bags a little bit of
space over the space Italy they have
[ __ ] two bags and I'm just like you
know this is just every [ __ ] I
understand they're for like 50 [ __ ]
minutes wait for my [ __ ] bag it's
just like that [ __ ] Airport
it just breaks your goddamn spirit
because every [ __ ] time it's a
different [ __ ] over and so you never see
it coming if that always happened I
would be like okay here's the deal I'm
not checking a bag or if I check the bag
you'd be like just settle in because you
know it's gonna be 50 minutes all right
go sit down get yourself some bangers
and mash whatever the [ __ ] it is these
people lead over here and you know show
up 45 minutes later and pick up your
[ __ ] bag what killed me is how
everybody else just accepted it and I
was the only person staying and they go
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this Airport
what do they got three [ __ ] baggage
handlers then what kill me is when they
finally started unloading the bags they
unload like five of them and then you
see people on your flight grabbing them
and then there's no more bags for like
ten minutes it's like what the [ __ ]
happened the guy doing it just to have a
[ __ ] stroke there's nobody back there
to help him you get like concerned but
it wasn't concerned I was selfish all I
gave a [ __ ] was about was my bag so
anyways I get my [ __ ] bag and I make
it over here to the hotel and after the
night before I was played the three
arena in Dublin one of my favorite shows
those [ __ ] people are just and it's
like double specific to Dublin they're
like the best [ __ ] hecklers I don't
even know how but they made like 911
funny just in an absurd way I was on
stage and I was talking about like how
much the country changed you know since
the 9/11 when I said 9/11 summing the
crowd went woo you know and they might
have been an American agreeing like oh
yeah you know the country did really
change after that just kind of an
obvious statement now that I'm repeating
it but the way they did it it made it
seem like they were cheering on 9/11
so I rift about that I said oh yeah you
you excited about tragedies oh yeah I
you know I've always hated skyscrapers I
just said
something like that it made everybody
laugh so then I started the joke again
how'd it go you know ever since 9/11 and
then the whole crowd goes blue just to
be dicks you know so then I roll with it
and I just start start every [ __ ]
joke now with some American tragedy as
gay
bla bla bla bla bla and I believe that
was around Pearl Harbor they know I'll
go who's so [ __ ] childish and stupid
right so after like the third one I said
I got you know what Ireland I really
wish I knew about your [ __ ] tragedies
alright but I'm an American I don't have
time to care about other countries and
it was just like this little [ __ ]
stupid insight back and forth thing that
will never happen at another show and I
don't know it was just the classic
classic I don't know Dublin crab I had
such a [ __ ] great I came it's just
such a [ __ ] great city so then I go
over last night to do Royal Albert Hall
and I don't even know how to describe it
like I still feel like it was like I
dreamed it like it didn't really it went
by so goddamn fast and when you walk in
there if you're a fan of Led Zeppelin
that place essentially looks the exact
same as it did when you watch you know
that concert footage though I'm for my
money the best concert footage of Led
Zeppelin that exists just the way it
looks the way it shot that film I tried
to do a stand-up special to kit to make
it look like that I just can't do it
it's just all that's yeah I guess you'd
have to film it but I just walked right
out I was like John Bonham's [ __ ]
that that maple kid he had was right
[ __ ] here it was crazy and then when
I got announced to go out like
was that constant or not there's one
where Robert Plant walks off stage and
grabs a joint smokes it and holds it up
to the camera like that's what I thought
was such a [ __ ] it was the weirdest
experience walking out because I felt
like I'd been there already
just cuz I've watched that concert film
so many times and no I didn't get a
chance to play drums cuz I did the show
in Dublin the night before which I had
to do because you know I had to make
sure I did one show in Europe you know
if there's always at just a little bit
of a different vibe so I had you know
that was more important you know to have
a good show than to you know go there
and hack away at the drums for like an
hour but believe me I definitely got my
money's worth the crowd was [ __ ]
amazing and I just had this whole weird
feeling the entire time I was up there
like why am I so relaxed with the
combination of holy [ __ ] I'm in Royal
Albert Hall and then you know I actually
[ __ ] up a couple of jokes because I
was looking at the architecture I can't
[ __ ] believe I'm here my parents came
out my wife came out for the show my
manager an agent came out and it was
just awesome it was like everybody you
know I I can't if you ever get a chance
to come over here and see anything there
it really is just one of those places
and I put some photos up on Instagram
and yeah that's it and now now old Billy
Boy is on vacation I think I did like an
hour and 15 minutes in the show and I
was sitting there going I forgot to look
at my watch and I was like I can't tell
if I've been up here for an hour and a
half 40 minutes a half hour or a little
over an hour because I I don't know I
don't think since Carnegie Hall there's
been a couple of places that you play
and you just like I shouldn't be here
that's what you're thinking just looking
and how beautiful it is and then see
like when you walk
to the dressing room you can't help but
look at the photos and I'm looking like
everyone from Freddie Mercury David
Bowie Frank Sinatra in like 1963
evidently the [ __ ] Beatles and The
Rolling Stones played there on the same
bill you know and then I'm walking out
there going like hey you know what the
[ __ ] up with chairs and you just you
know you're actress just shrinks down
you know I was kind of the thing he had
to like fight off but my agent asked me
like after the show he goes so what
venue do you want to play next here in
London I was like this one hey you know
what the [ __ ] do you go from here and
they're all like well you know it's like
booked three years out I'm like I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't care you know
unbelievable so thank you so much to
everybody you know who came out to the
show and afterwards I was able to you
know run out there and say hello to some
people signed some posters and I
appreciate the people that hung out and
were patient because like I said I had a
lot of family and friends back there you
know there's sort of my pre-birthday
celebration they had a cake and [ __ ]
like that so I had to do that and I ran
out there so you got tired of waiting
for them and you left I apologize but
for the record I did come out and the
people there were just like ridiculously
nice and you know there's all these
people I had like I had like three
people from Poland going you got to do a
show in Poland somebody from Romania
somebody from Jordan when I was in
Dublin I did a show there was this dude
from Hong Kong told me he flew in
because he saw a clip of me on Conan
O'Brien how [ __ ] crazy is the
internet that there's some guy in Hong
Kong watching clips of the Conan O'Brien
show and then he sees me as a guest
Conan makes me look good as always and
now he wants to come to my show he goes
I got tickets for the the Dublin show
and the London show
and he was there by himself I was just
like all right this guy's either gonna
stab me or this is one of the coolest
people I've ever met in my life
fortunately it was the latter so anyways
now I'm on vacation I'm on vacation do
you guys realize the next part this is
my last podcast in my forty's man Oh
[ __ ] Billy over the hill way to do
doo doo doo doo I'm turning [ __ ] 50
on Sunday Sunday Sunday
um I actually feel good you know I don't
I'm not gonna feel any [ __ ] different
I don't think between now and Sunday
other than when somebody says how old do
you I don't say 4 I say fear no 50
that's it
Oh Billy Oh Billy red nuts is 50 [ __ ]
years old what would ever thunk it so
anyway so then we end up hanging out we
went out to a bar afterwards only had a
couple of drinks smoked an unbelievable
cigar and then there was like this
little casino thing that we went to me
my manager my agent and my lovely wife
ordered some dim sum and at like [ __ ]
2:00 in the morning we watched game for
the NBA Finals which was a great game
once again but it's just Golden State
has too many [ __ ] too many people man
it's like I don't know I guess it's
genius that the NBA lets these teams
become what they are I guess with all
the [ __ ] everybody piling on because
then guys like me I just watch
rooting against that team but uh you
know it's kind of boring though you know
the last two years the NBA kind of
knowing at the beginning of the season
well yeah obviously these guys
are gonna win it and then they do I mean
this is not even like I don't know
remember that do you remember that you
know what I couldn't get into I couldn't
get into the dream team when we went to
the Olympics and they were dunking on
Ethiopians and [ __ ] I was just looking
like this it was the most boring [ __ ]
and they always talked about that team
like that was the greatest assemblage of
talent in basketball history yet going
up against probably the weakest I would
rather watch the Globetrotters play the
[ __ ] Washington Generals they watched
the Dream Team play [ __ ] Rwanda
whatever the hell we were doing that
year you know I mean but what was good
about that was they so kicked the [ __ ]
out of everybody that sense then you
know Europe like raised the bar the way
they play now and now some of the best
players in the league are from Europe
which was unheard of when I was growing
up so I guess I don't know something
good will come out of this Golden State
warrior team that they'll just be I
don't know all the stars will be on two
teams they should just take the all-star
team in the east and the West right and
just just have that be the league right
or at least just have them go to the NBA
Finals and then you just get what to
watch everybody try and as opposed to
the all-star game when nobody pays any
defense I don't [ __ ] know so anyways
[Music]
that's it man I did Royal Albert Hall
part of the history old freckles it's
part of that I can't [ __ ] believe it
I can't believe it I was saying that to
somebody I said you really [ __ ] 26
years ago you sign up for a stupid
[ __ ] open mic and it leads to this
never never in my wildest dreams would I
ever think I would ever sell one ticket
in London you know or any place in
Europe forget about getting to play that
place so that one you know there's ones
that stay with you
[Music]
that's definitely one you know the 911
show that will stay with me absurdity of
that the vicar Street one that I did
Dublin I had a great one in Oslo my
first really good show in Europe these
are all the European ones that stick
Germany was fun when I was teasing him
about Hitler I've had so much [ __ ]
fun over here I just got to figure out
how to do these dates now that I got the
kid oh but everybody's over here by the
way
my lovely daughter is here she's such a
riot she woke up this morning like you
know I stayed out late right so
obviously she you know mia gets her up
in everything she puts her in the bed
she's next to me and I have my eyes
closed and then she just I just she
looks over me she just goes hi I start
cracking up and then she left and that's
that's just it's the greatest way ever
to start the date Nia how much fun was
last night what are we doing today we're
gonna go get some bangers and mash and
mushy peas yeah okay you look beautiful
Nene I like your dress so what we're
gonna do today hey if anybody lives in
here lives around London if you know a
place where they have good food please
text me the dim sum yes it was great
last night but uh I don't know we've
been kind of striking out here I know
there has to be good fruit here there
has to be okay everybody has the Food
Network there has to be some food in
London that's actually seasoned
correctly I don't underst
I just don't get it
you know I mean they got salt and pepper
but after that it just goes off the
rails that [ __ ] guy that the Hell's
Kitchen guys from here people from here
can cook where the [ __ ] are they
go ahead and Ramsay does he got a reason
well I don't know if I want to go to his
restaurant cuz you know those celebrity
chefs say they'll own their name to
something it's hit or miss some of them
are involved other room just like how
much yeah I don't give a [ __ ] put my
[ __ ] name on it anyways so tonight
I'm gonna try to find a place where I
can watch potentially the Washington
Capitals when their first Stanley Cup
they've been in the league since 1974
god bless them their 45th season I
really want to see Ovechkin get a cup
you know I don't know why but also you
know then the other side is if Vegas
comes back you know in every Washington
Capitals they're just [ __ ] hung their
head cuz they know if anybody could blow
a [ __ ] 3-1 lead but I just think this
this capitols team is different I'm not
trying to jinx them or anything like
that I'm just gonna [ __ ] you know I'm
not into that stupid sports jinx [ __ ]
okay this [ __ ] team like you know the
coaching that's going on here you know
they saw who the Knights were and gave
one and they said oh is that how you
play well here's our adjustment to it
and goddamnit
they've won the next three in a row and
I really hope I get to find a place
where I can watch that game maybe I'll
go back down to the casino again and
watch it but uh
oh man that reminds me has time I
watched a Patriots game when I was in
Australia at a [ __ ] casino at like
4:00 in the morning I think it was 4:00
in the morning the next day and I was
watching Sun it was for the morning on
Monday in Australia and I was watching
Sunday afternoon football it's like a 14
now I think I was watching the 1 o'clock
game or something it's like a 14 hour is
it a 14
a difference no it's like that's how
long the flight is is 14 hours I can't
[ __ ] remember it's something
ridiculous like that so anyways I didn't
know if I have any [ __ ] advertising
[Music]
yeah I don't know what to tell you
that's it it's actually sunny out here
in London I was worried that it was
going to be all [ __ ] shitty weather
oh by the way you know I ended up being
like ridiculous traffic get into the
getting to the venue last night because
they were building some new hotel called
the Mandarin out here and they had some
massive fire like half something like
half the firefighters in in all of
London were there fight in the [ __ ]
thing thank God like you know the hotel
wasn't open yet although that wasn't
what I was saying in my shelf I was so
upset about the [ __ ] traffic of
Santos wish it was full of people maybe
there would have been less traffic on
the road Oh bill why would you why why
why would you say something like that so
that [ __ ] burned down probably an
insurance job you know I wonder one more
thing actually looked that up right now
on my European internet which is gonna
have all kinds of [ __ ] dude they
literally had an advertisement for
[ __ ] field hockey over here it's like
field hockey is that if that's a that's
a sport like on TV sport I know it's a
sport they gots they just got some weird
[ __ ] over here when it comes to the
sports stuff you know let me guess I'm
not [ __ ] signed in right oh you
[ __ ] so-and-so Wi-Fi and to your room
number and to your last name you know
what today casino last night they asked
for my driver's license they want to
take like a [ __ ] picture of me that
was in such a good mood I let him do all
of that I'm like well I guess I mean
your system now they go no no no we
don't we don't we don't keep it it's
like yeah you do you're taking a [ __ ]
picture of me
like where does all of that go you know
I just got a [ __ ] phone call a
message from American Airlines saying
that somebody got my frequent flyer
number and might have been trying to see
where I was flying and blah blah blah
and all of this [ __ ] and it's just
like so we need you you know we need you
to call us and blah blah blah it's like
what the [ __ ] do I gotta call you guys
for why don't you guys fix your [ __ ]
weak-ass system this isn't on me I love
like when like your information might
have been compromised you call them up
and they tell you what you need to do
it's like no you know what you need to
do stop putting everything up on [ __ ]
computers go back to [ __ ] notebooks
and pens so [ __ ] it like the paper trail
that you leave it's really impossible no
that's what [ __ ] kills me about that
guy that almost went to jail but he sat
next to Larry David at the Dodgers game
it's like there was no record of that
guy anywhere paying for parking getting
a hot dog his cell phone they couldn't
track it to the game you know he didn't
go through some intersection where there
was a camera with his Dodger hat on
going into the [ __ ] Carlito's Way
canyon whatever the [ __ ] Dodgers play
Carlito's Canyon what the hell is it
called Chavez Ravine huh I don't know
anyways what the [ __ ] was I looking up
Oh London fire so I'm gonna do a bunch
of touristy [ __ ] I think today with my
parents hopefully if they're up for it
you know I don't think I've ever seen
Buckingham Palace I like that dude who
just got married by the way I don't
there's just something about his face
you like this you know you can just see
how much he's gonna annoy the [ __ ] out
of his wife accidentally come on man can
you [ __ ] just for once Internet can
you work for me
London Fire Hotel Safari can't verify
the identify continue I don't give a
[ __ ]
my stuff's already been compromised
login I did login please select do you
accept the terms that we're gonna take
all of your [ __ ] and then call you later
and say somebody that we don't know got
it and they're now in the dark web
looking at [ __ ] kiddie porn alright
you were logged in okay wonderful London
it's the last time I'm trying to miss
everybody London via bill burns it up
last night at the [ __ ] sorry you go
just kicked in the London Fire Brigade
no that's not what I want fire brigade
that sounds like a [ __ ] musical hotel
fire [ __ ] London alright here we go
what do we got here Mandarin Oriental
huge blaze - look at that [ __ ] thing
sorry you need flash to play this enable
it in your browser out go [ __ ] yourself
plumes of smoke Hey look who's here hi
huh how you doing buddy okay cool okay
you you got it all right bye
all right a total of 36 hotel guests in
250 members of the hotel staff were
evacuated all there were [ __ ] people
in there singer Robbie Williams was
among them I don't know who Robbie
Williams is that sounds like a teen idol
even if he's old or she right the blaze
reach or they the blaze reached several
floors but was quickly extinguished for
those the London Fire Brigade said the
London fire
we gave Nia the fire brigade not to
firefighters not the [ __ ] hook and
ladder welcome they never do the hook
and lateral play anymore in the NFL
never one of that it always seemed to
work back in the day huh are you gonna
watch the NHL hockey with me tonight
no why not you love sports you just
don't realize it yet sorry about that
just planning our damn day here billows
and billows Robbie Williams 44 describes
the drama I went on the balcony and
looked up and there was just billows and
billows of smoke I came back in from the
balcony and said the hotel's on fire and
this guy's a smart [ __ ] it's a smart
guy and then the hotel's on fire and
there's a lot of smoke by me what else
would you say he really he got the
information out the hotels on fire I
probably would have came back in and
wouldn't be like Mia what the [ __ ]
did I was you know added all these extra
words and then the next thing a knock at
the door came and there was a bellboy
there and they said get out I like this
this is very who's that playwright that
just has really [ __ ] choppy dialogue
like that or like when you watch Law &
Order you know they have to get so much
information and they actually time your
lines when you do an episode of that
show they don't care about emotion that
just like say it faster alright Williams
and his wife Ida Feld 39 ran down an
external fire escape to safety oh
there's a video I don't need flash for
that man that's a beautiful hotel I
thought it was under construction wait a
minute
wow you know what
billows and billows of smoke well what
started it all right can't emphasize
enough how well the evacuation operation
has been put together now being moved to
a nearby a hotel for safety well who
gives a [ __ ] about you ah you can't say
that this is how it is everyth
everything's about everybody you know
right hotels on fire shaking my head lol
[ __ ] my life
Yolo he's a guy just wrote hope you are
okay Ana subtext
I'd like to comfort you / maybe turning
into some sort of sexual activity
alright I think that's a good place to
end alright and there's a good friend of
mine out here in London says I am now in
vacation and I am gonna laze about doing
[ __ ] off and then that's it and then I
come back to LA and I'm gonna get this
[ __ ] hour of [ __ ] whipped into shape
and maybe do another special I don't
know I don't know what I'm supposed to
do in this new landscape of 15 minutes
specials hours specials
who knows I got to figure out what the
[ __ ] next move is so I can keep
coming over here and having an
unbelievable time sorry if this podcast
wasn't funny I'm still kind of floating
from what happened last night I still
cannot believe I got to do that it's
just yeah no words speechless they
actually have me to sign the book you
know and I'd like to you to sign the
guestbook and Royal Albert after you did
the gig and once again I can barely
remember I wrote something like that
just speechless you know I don't know
what I didn't want to say so I just said
thanks thanks for letting a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and dick jokes over here
spent an hour and 15 minutes on that
stage can't [ __ ] believe it
unbelievable alright that's it enjoy the
music and I'll talk to you when I'm in
my 50s
oh alright here's a couple of
advertisements here expressvpn you know
with all the news lately about data
hacks and breaches data hacks and
breaches sorry it's hard for me not to
worry about my digital privacy well
there's an understatement no matter what
you do online your prop your mobile
carrier Internet service provider are
tracking it all bastards Comcast Verizon
Time Warner the list goes on these nosy
bastards are trying to figure out what
you're doing companies like these have a
record of every single thing you do
every website you visit every email you
send it's ridiculous so that's why I
decided to take my privacy back by using
Express VPN is that what I did wasn't
aware of that these days I don't use the
internet without it I hate when they
write copy like this I totally believe
in this if this is what they're going to
do how about that with expressvpn your
internet data is encrypted and your IP
address is hidden expressvpn cost less
than seven bucks a month and it's rated
the number one VPN service by tech radar
and dozens of expert reviewers
expressvpn has easy-to-use apps that run
seamlessly in the background of your
computer phone and tablet turning on
expressvpn protection only takes a click
no matter what you do online whether you
have something to hide yes or you think
you don't that you don't expressvpn
is for you if you're on unsecured Wi-Fi
and want to keep hackers and spies from
seeing your data expressvpn is for you
well they just watch a bunch of slap
fights and motorcycle videos with me and
occasional porn and if you don't want
providers like Verizon recording your
entire online history and then selling
it to the whole world expressvpn is for
you to take back your internet privacy
today and find out how you can get three
months free
go to expressvpn comm / / that's Express
exp ress VPN comm / / for three months
breathe with a one year package every
day you use the internet without
expressvpn you're putting your sensitive
information at risk don't pull this off
don't put this off sorry protect your
online data with expressvpn today visit
expressvpn calm / / to learn mo alright
next one here post mates I use these
guys as usual your stomach and the rest
of your life are at war you need to eat
but you can't stop what you're doing to
deal with it and not the only and the
only things what and the only fast
things that deliver are not what you
want that means you don't want fast food
why don't these people realize I'm dumb
next please mention all the talk course
I'm going to mention these introducing
post mates the app that adds a delivery
option to your favorite restaurants
imagine anything you want to eat
delivered you don't have to drive park
or even sit up they'll throw it right
through the window you don't have to
talk on a phone to order just draw
download the app and order 24 hours a
day 365 days 24 hours a day 365 post
mates will bring you what you want
within the hour
god I need glasses you can see your food
what you can see where your food is and
track your driver it's kind of creepy
you forgot to get eggs and milk no
problem craving a tasty burger check
looking for the bet the perfect bottle
of red wine or summer beer order up post
mates is your new long-term munchies
booty call I don't want a little
sideways for a limited time post mate
why don't we kill hooker we got you for
a limited time post mates is giving you
$100 of free delivery credit for your
first 7 days to start your free
deliveries download the app today and
use the code birbee you are r100 that's
BER 100
that's code BER 100 for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
save the hassle man get the food you
love fast at
host mates with the code burr 100 all
right lastly but not leastly hims hims
is that hairline slowly starting to move
backwards whatta hell was this seven
years ago any bald spots yet yeah all
over my head how will you feel a year
from now if you're if it's business as
usual up there I asked you do you want a
bald spot to pop up or do you want to do
something about it first do you realize
how big a vat of whatever the hell this
is there's enough to sell me do you want
your hairline to recede or do you want
to do something about it first why do
guys turn to weird solutions or do
nothing well it's called [ __ ] being a
man you [ __ ] I don't like how
they're insulting me here
when they can turn to medicine and
science for hemes dot-com a one-stop
shop shop for hair loss skin care sexual
wellness for men thanks to science
baldness can be optional hims connects
you with real doctors and medical grade
solutions to treat hair loss well I was
never really a good-looking fellow
anyway so this is like putting mag
wheels on a piece of [ __ ] like but if
you guys are good-looking this is a
great product well known generic
equivalents to name-brand prescriptions
to help you keep your hair no snake oil
pills or gas station counter supplements
prescription solution backed by science
no waiting room no awkward doctor visits
save hours by going to for him is calm
answer a few quick questions doctor will
review and prescribe you products are
shipped directly to your door my
listeners my listeners get a trial month
of hymns for just five dollars today
right now while supplies last see the
website for full details this would cost
hundreds if you went to the doctor or a
pharmacy go to hims calm / / that's for
him sorry f o r h IMS calm / / for hims
calm / / Wilma
as I said at the runway for hims calm /
/
[Music]
why don't we I got sucked right now I
did a show in Dublin Ireland and all the
crowds were great but I got to tell you
those [ __ ] people in Ireland are the
funnies that I can't even explain I
swear it well there's something about
like when I go through Great Britain and
Ireland
it's like Scotland and Ireland they like
the knucklehead so that I grew up with
and when I go to London London is like
was is kind of like all the people that
I met when I went to New York that were
from Boston so they they did move away
from where they were from but they still
brought that thing with them because
people in London are hilarious but I was
doing a show Dublin on Monday night at
the the vicar vicar street theatre or
something just this awesome venue and
anyway so it was on a Monday night and
it's a really hard night to try and sell
tickets and these people showed up in
force and I can't even tell you how big
they were [ __ ] hilarious like I was
on stage and there was this thing I was
talking about about people hugging their
kids and now that could put is a good
thing but if you do it too much you
could potentially make a week or so I
mentioned and all I've been telling this
story for like six to eight months and
I've been saying how that you know my
mother wasn't a hug hugger and didn't
hug us when we were kids
and people just listen and it's just a
small detail that leads to this other
part that I want to talk about so I've
said that line uneventful II that's even
a [ __ ] work with with knoweth no
issue whatsoever for like six months now
I'm in [ __ ] Ireland and I just throw
that lying out there like I'm not even
thinking about him say yeah I said you
know my mother didn't hug me when I was
a kid and I'm getting ready to say the
next sentence and like 15 percent of the
crowd goes oh oh
I'm not even doing it the way they did
it just collectively broke my ball it
was just such the classic [ __ ] it was
like that Boston Irish thing that I grew
up with distilled to its purest form
with actually real Irish people where I
you know must have to be that a [ __ ]
understand what was behind it it was
like he opened the emotional door just a
crack and automatically
it's just they just bust your balls
about it like yeah you [ __ ] you know
what you think they think we got hugs
you're freckled can't shut the [ __ ] up
and tell the judge I can't even just I
I've been trying to I would tried to
explain it to me as she laughed but it
still yeah you kind of had to be there
and then you know so I had laughs I'm
not [ __ ] trying to get your sympathy
I'm trying to get to this next part you
[ __ ] on the whole crowd [ __ ]
laughs hey when I was growing up you
know my mother never hugged us we didn't
come from a family like that island of
no hugs I have your blood in me so
[ __ ] look at that that's totally what
that was
my mum's dead naga see then you [ __ ]
what are you fiction about you [ __ ] for
the love of God let me get through it
alright do you [ __ ] country's I've
said that in and nobody said [ __ ]
[Applause]
goddamn Mary yes I guess you still have
bullying and then like a half hour later
what I had done when I was over there
was I bought a bunch of DVDs with me
like just the basically the DVD itself
with this little paper thing and I was
just handing them out to people cuz I'm
trying to get them to show other people
you know when I'm out there so I can
keep coming back basically trying to get
them to spread the word in my comedy and
it's almost just like well why don't you
just put it on Spotify yet dumb [ __ ] and
I'm like AK cuz I'm old
alright I feel like I have to bring the
hard copy so I tell these [ __ ] then
I'm giving them free DVDs at the end of
the show
I'm halfway through that spiel telling
him that they're getting a free DVD
alright and I'm in the middle of it and
I hear this guy in the back that guy
goes out [ __ ] I don't even think I
didn't even explained what I was doing I
don't know if I had gotten to the part
where they were free I don't know what
the [ __ ] or was the fact that I was
trying to Swanson
well hey you know I really appreciate
you guys coming out this really means a
lot to me and I want to keep coming back
here cuz I think you got a great [ __ ]
country or whatever and I just just
opening the door that much so I finally
just looked on with Jesus Christ they
were already laughing I was like you
know what I've played in 20 almost 22
years as a comedian I have played in
front of some miserable [ __ ]
but you guys and they were already
laughing other
most miserable [ __ ] [ __ ] I've ever
been and they loved it absolutely loved
it and it killed me that I couldn't go
out drinking with the crowd because I
had a [ __ ] go I had an early flight
of course all the way over to Helsinki
have to take one dude I can't tell you
I've been to some miserable [ __ ]
[Applause]
miserable like just got some DVDs a
complimentary [ __ ] off don't you just
you sounded like I drove into the back
of your car and I thought why do you
want like a d [ __ ] off fix my [ __ ]
car giving you a goddamn show
[Music]
I did to Kilkenny festival and Kilkenny
Ireland and that one I don't remember
mayonnaise on fries as much as I
remember how many pints of Guinness I
drank and this club got hammered and
this great laugh that I had with Dom I
rera
me and Dom I like we were just like we
were like cliff and Norma Cheers
and just walking around that city and
everybody else would go to bed and we
would still be like carousing right so
one night we're walking up
it's like [ __ ] at probably 2:00 in
the morning on like a Sunday night so
you know sleepy town everybody's asleep
we're walking up these cobblestones in
the [ __ ] moonlight all right like
werewolves and London [ __ ] it had rained
so they like the moonlight was
glistening nice and we're walking up and
it's [ __ ] quiet as hell and we're
drunk and were laughing but try not to
you know waiting for somebody to throw
up and the shutter it's like you
acquired here right and we walking up
the thing and we're trying to find a bar
that's still open and all of a sudden we
just heard these these you know these
Irish singers okay what time was this
this was like 2:00 in the morning on a
Sunday night so we just start following
the sound of them singing come up these
cobblestones and then tell us at the
beginning of a great movie right came up
and we comes down we see the light on
this bar and we come walking in by the
time we get in you know this guy was
singing with two other people and they
had gone up to the bar so it was only
one guy singing when we came walking in
and we come walking in and it's just a
bunch of town he's sitting there way
more seats than people a little empty
but a small place and there's guys
onstage just singing
hatee-hatee-hatee-ho he's singing this
[ __ ] thing right and we're taking the
bar and we look and there's this guy
sitting right in front of the stage and
dude he was passed out at a level you'd
never get this drunk in an American Bar
they'd send you home dude this guy he
looks good
this guy was completely passed I'll
never forget he had one arm was slung
over the back of the chair and then his
head was just hanging straight down when
he stood behind him you couldn't see his
head you just saw like his that this is
neck hang in there it looked like he had
gotten shot and we walked in and nobody
was really talking
and this guy's slumped over and all we
hear is it and everybody turns around
and looks at us and meanwhile that guy's
in the background going green alligator
long goose or whatever and look at each
other and it was like one of those
things were we now we can't leave so we
uh we walk up to the bar and they asked
you know really thick Irish brogue what
we wanted ordered a couple of guinnesses
and I'm sitting there trying to hold it
together cuz I know I can't look at dumb
and I'm hearing Dom starting to laugh
and this guy's still singing and Dom
starts Dom starts riffing he starts
riffing lyrics to what this guy's
singing he's just in my ear going I got
myself up okay and he's doing this thing
and dude we started we started [ __ ]
laughing and we couldn't stop like two
screws and the whole thing was what was
keeping it going was if there's tension
like in like in high school or middle
school when the teacher goes the next
person who laughs yeah gets [ __ ]
detention like that tension makes you
you can't stop [ __ ] no no yeah so we
knew they were looking at and I'm
getting nervous like they think we're
laughing at their country and all this
so I'm trying to be polite and not laugh
at all it just it just dude it was this
[ __ ] wave of laughing I remember I've
never seen Dom like I was looking at he
literally like his mouth was open and he
had tears it what and then what was
cracking me up was it looked like almost
like he was crying in that but that guy
was singing was making me cry so then
there was another wave of laughs oh my
god the guys just launched over and in
the whole time and then the bartender
would look at me like what the [ __ ] you
laughing at and I would look over look
away and all I could look at what's this
guy's lumped over there's this guy on
stage and he was singing he had his
eyebrows up
and he was hitting these [ __ ] high
notes until it was it was torture but it
was a great laugh but it was that whole
thing probably took all of four minutes
but like Mike Mike Mike
my stomach was [ __ ] killing oh my god
I would have loved to see I would've
loved somewhere in those adventures I
oh that's a great story
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on it's bill burns the
Monday morning podcast for June 7th 2010
how the hell are you what's going on are
you better Jesus Christ I can't get away
from that [ __ ] oil spill you know try
to go out to a bar you try to drink your
troubles away and every time I look up
there's some [ __ ] greasy bird getting
picked up by a scientist you know I like
I wouldn't you know when they pick up
the bird they still have to make sure
that the bird doesn't like [ __ ] bite
the [ __ ] out of him still was picking up
a pelican you know and he's got his he's
got his gardener glove and he's holding
the beak shut he's [ __ ] stupid
animals it's like dude I'm trying to
help you you know can't help you if you
don't want help
you know you dumb [ __ ] look at me I
wanted to eat you would I be gingerly
picking you up why are you trying to
bite me that [ __ ] you're covered in his
oil
all right you dumb [ __ ] if you want such
a stupid bird you'd understand the gas
combustion engine you know um
anyways whatever blaming the victim here
it's [ __ ] unreal ma'am can they just
cap that [ __ ] all right you know how
dumb am i do can it contagious you can't
they just put a top on it you know for
the first time actually looked at the
spill there's certain things that I just
can't watch the second I heard what was
going on down there it's like I'm not
gonna watch that [ __ ] because I have
absolutely no power to to stop it all I
can do is just sit there watching it
going [ __ ] you know whatever what are
you gonna do what the [ __ ] do you stop
it wants the loo I'm kind of handicapped
this week people as I had a crazy
[ __ ] weekend and my broad is still
sleeping in the other room so this is
gonna be one of those medium energy
podcasts oh [ __ ] you
alright [ __ ] you whoever just sighed
whoever just roll
you [ __ ] eyes right you don't have a
medium energy day where you don't put in
the [ __ ] effort you know like
what's-his-face that power for for the
[ __ ] Lakers who's full of gummi bears
and every other [ __ ] game as sugar
crashes and he's not worth his [ __ ]
I always think his name is uh not Lamar
Odom I always think it's Riley Odom who
I believe was a guy who played for the
[ __ ] Broncos Riley Odom's in the 70s
what was it haven Moses I don't know I
don't know where these names come
through but I'm sick you know everybody
[ __ ] talking about the goddamn oil
spill you know acting like human beings
are the [ __ ] worst but down there
we're trying to help these filthy
animals and and in the effort to help
them this there's still attacking us you
know it's like dude I can't help you you
know you have to want help okay you got
it you got to want to change you got to
want to come out of the muck dude all
right I gotta [ __ ] pull you one of
this sludge and cover your mouth at the
same [ __ ] time what was this some
sort of jujitsu some animal jujitsu oh
Jesus
morning sweetheart what was with that
little deer okay you know some days when
your significant other walks by you you
just know this is one of these days you
know those couple of points that I want
to make in the relationship I'll wait
til tomorrow to try to make those points
whew Jesus Christ she looked like a
[ __ ] future hall-of-fame quarterback
in the twilight of her career in the
morning you know that's how she when she
walked by Jesus Christ that was such a
great [ __ ] reference and I butchered
it she looked like a future
hall-of-famer in the Twilight I think I
did it backwards hey what happens if you
pull a pit bulls tail mmm you like that
Cleo you're like I don't pull it I just
hold on to it all right get out of my
face look at you you're not covered in
oil would you try to bite me if I pulled
you out you wouldn't you be sitting
there going alright so anyways speaking
of the Lakers and Celtics this is just a
[ __ ] insane time of the year
with the NBA Finals and the NHL Finals
are on at the same time you know and
women just go crazy because they're
loving it they're loving every second of
the sports my girl watches every [ __ ]
TV show that involves let's take the
dumbest [ __ ] form the stupidest state
and just start documenting their family
you know and then then the people start
ramping up the stupid because the
cameras are on I went in there she was
watching something they had just a bunch
of dumb skanks from Jersey planning a
[ __ ] wedding and rather than
addressing the real issue which is that
these people are gonna [ __ ] procreate
they're actually dealing with this
little [ __ ] about oh my god I want to
wish you fine and all my skanky
bridesmaids you know what they're
scraped out uterus is from all those
abortions have to wear the same [ __ ]
color I mean that's television people I
don't think it is it's not television
how do we go from Lawrence Welk to that
number when we had Family Values
Lawrence Welk had so many morals it was
actually creepy a bun and the tulle
wanna go on YouTube and go look up the
Lawrence Welk Show there was a dance
team on there Bobby and Susie or
something just the whitest purist
let's go spoon with Jesus [ __ ] white
names you could ever come up with and I
used to do these they used to [ __ ]
dance these stupid smiles on their face
and it was just that classic little
Skippy do Skippy do all across the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] stupid dance floor you know
you know they both had [ __ ] eating
disorders as goddamn dancers you gotta
have the body of a [ __ ] seventh grade
of your entire life it's like you're 35
years old
what are you eat huh [ __ ] a handful
of cottage cheese before you go out the
goddamn door Cleo get out get away from
me come on you sniff it up my feet I'm
trying to focus here dogs are so [ __ ]
emotional look at that look on your face
you really just had a sad look on your
now you're making me feel bad mm-hmm
anyways talking about the Lawrence Welk
Show go look that [ __ ] up it was just it
was just it was [ __ ] horrible
some of those shows back then you know
that's that's kind of like what I grew
up on you know I just saw those shows
and I sat down and watched it for the
longest time that was like music to me
you know and I asked for I want a record
I wanted I wanted some music for my
birthday at that I don't know what I
didn't know what it was I just wanted a
record give me a record and the first
record I was given was sing along with
Mitch in the gang it was a Mitch Miller
record you know I always wonder why I
never got laid in high school but you
know when you're when you're weaned on
roll out the barrel these other kids at
singing like [ __ ] Aerosmith and Led
Zeppelin and I'm I won't you come home
Bill Bailey won't you come home you know
what kind of kid in the third grade
wants to play the banjo I didn't know
any better I didn't know that there was
electric guitar
I actually liked a tuba [ __ ] Mickey
Finn huh the [ __ ] something a robert
e lee that was like one of my favorite
song Ted Heath Orchestra Elks parade
those are my jams I used to sit there
and eat out normal kids would sit there
and they'd listen to like some [ __ ]
you know classic rock and then fantasize
about being able to play it in front of
all the [ __ ] hot broads in their 14th
fifth-grade class you know normal
fantasies I was actually thinking about
playing the trumpet solo on one o'clock
jump that'll get them bill they'll have
them all lined up you know the extra
saliva mouths with their [ __ ] braces
I always loved that when kids got braces
I lucked out I never had to have braces
the kids had braces and like that
they'll give body thinking its food for
the first [ __ ] two weeks trying to
break it down - pull her in sexual um
[ __ ] elastic bands what are these
[ __ ] [ __ ] kids have nowadays where
they got that they got that Clear
Channel [ __ ] they put in there whatever
[ __ ] is the clear I was that the [ __ ]
stuff - yeah athletes take I don't [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] isn't you know that that
[ __ ] where it's just a plastic mouth
guard you put it in your mouth and
you'll have to go through the torture
that kids you know from my grade had to
go through this is like really that's
like old school stand-up material you
know having to go there and get your
[ __ ] braces tightened you know right
now Mike Mike Mike Mike Mike Mike my my
my computer screen went to the save mode
and what it does is it puts up all the
albums that I've downloaded onto my do
she [ __ ] iPod which sucks which
breaks every six months or needs to be
updated because he can't handle the new
technology I've and I have a nice mix of
music here Gordon Lightfoot oh this is
some easy listening [ __ ] sting Godsmack
let me try to get some credibility
houses of the Holy
one of the worst Led Zeppelin albums
ever except for two songs the rain song
and [ __ ] no quarter the crunch is I'm
gonna elect is one of the worst songs
ever written by a great band Oh Stevie
Wonder what is that one songs in the key
of a and is a jay-z one I don't know why
I have that which one is that one is
that the one one he was gonna retire but
then he didn't lam a god the Romantics
remember that one what I like about you
when they had the red suits on red
leather suits and there was nothing
wrong with it um that one with Justin
Timberlake steps on the crystal ball the
disco ball because he was bringing sexy
back
remember that wham wham wham Neil Young
Harvest Moon Merle Travis look at me I'm
all over the [ __ ] map 1950
hits and highlights the nerves any this
best of brick Jeff Beck truth that album
remember that one that had half a Led
Zeppelin one Jaco Pastorius Audioslave
it's a supergroup okay
let's plow ahead here um I started to
talk about Lakers Celtics and I'm gonna
extend an olive branch right now and
rather than doing the usual and going
off and that type of [ __ ] I want I wanna
you know and I'm heaving a dragon the
hockey fans to I want to talk right now
to fans are the Celtics the Lakers the
Blackhawks and the Flyers because I I
got a question cuz I'm having a [ __ ]
heart attack I'm aging like seven years
which eat with each point that is scored
are not scored in the Celtics Laker
series and I gotta ask you good big
sports fans out there why do we give a
[ __ ] you know what it's it's [ __ ]
it's stupid
I get it I get I'm you know you were
this I give a [ __ ] so much said I'm
actually jealous of people who don't
give a [ __ ] like last night after I
watched the game like you know I felt
like I got I got acquitted or something
like that's the level of stress I'm just
sitting there you know like [ __ ] are
Kelly thinking there's no way there's no
[ __ ] way holy [ __ ] that video it
looks just like you I know but it's not
me you know all those years would be
offended when everybody says we all look
alike now I'm saying we all look alike
because I peed on a twelve-year-old
amongst other things
alright let's plow ahead here why do we
give a [ __ ] so that like I'm sitting
there like this is this is how much I
give a [ __ ]
I know you guys are gonna think this is
nuts I actually had an opportunity so at
the last second had a ticket to the game
it's a 20-minute [ __ ] ride down the
street and I turned it down
I turned it down because I
first of all I already went to an NBA
Finals game I already went okay so I
checked that off the bucket list I went
to the Lakers Celtics actually lost
Lakers Celtics final you know if you got
to go to a final game that's the great
thing and I went into enemy territory
with my [ __ ] Celtic shirt on and I
basically paid like 400 bucks or
whatever the [ __ ] to sit in the last row
of the Staples Center to every five
seconds to have somebody go Celtics
RBG's you know it's like I paid to get
verbally [ __ ] abused and to not hear
the commentating and all that type of
[ __ ] but it was still awesome to be
there but it's like I give a [ __ ] too
much I want to hear the goddamn game I
don't want to sit there and have to look
around fat [ __ ] and drunks getting up
to get their goddamn beer and listen to
their stupid [ __ ] I know it's it's not
worth I'm paying money to be tortured I
don't want to do it so I actually stayed
in my living room and I watched the game
on mute I can't even listen to the
[ __ ] announcers because they drive me
nuts and half of it is because sometimes
they say dumb [ __ ] and the other half is
because I'm so psychotically into my
team that I am convinced that everyone
in the booth hates my team secretly
hates my [ __ ] team I actually have a
debate with Paul virzi a comedian right
dude who opens up for me you people in
New York on the East Coast you've seen
him don't act like you haven't or even
down in Atlanta oh yeah the dude oh yeah
I don't name names he may or may not
have been the guy I went to [ __ ] the
Masters with and bet on the Turtles but
anyways he's convinced that Tim McCarver
hates the [ __ ] Yankees and I'm like
dude he hates the [ __ ] Red Sox and
then we just kind of came to a
conclusion that you know it's kind of in
our head and also that Tim McCarver
might might kind of be a douche a little
bit I think he likes the Cardinals
because that's how he played for but
whatever I'm getting off track like that
don't you wish you have a wish like
sometime
she didn't give a [ __ ] you know what I
mean like after I did my show and went
down I mean actually after I watched the
Lakers game I went down the street and I
did stand-up and I came walking in and I
was talking to some dude who was from
New Hampshire
so my call Celtics right he's like yeah
yeah goes they win tonight and I'm like
you [ __ ] dick you [ __ ] yeah they
want ya they want okay so now you get to
have the joy that they won and you
didn't have to go through the [ __ ]
cardiac arrest that I went through
oh it's unreal when the Lakers stopped
coming back I got a walk out of the
[ __ ] room literally I walk out of the
room come back in I peek peek back into
the [ __ ] my can't [ __ ] take it it's
like the oil spill it's like this
[ __ ] thing that I want to turn out
right and and it isn't and there's
nothing I can [ __ ] do about it I'm
just sitting there [ __ ] helpless you
know I don't know what I got a dude like
I gotta be on like a [ __ ] Stairmaster
like some broad while I watch it to get
that extra energy out I [ __ ] have
like every like seven minutes I'll take
the mute button off and I can listen to
a sentence and a half before Van Gundy
or somebody else all these these [ __ ]
guys who played the game coach the game
know way more about the game and I am
immediately convinced that they don't
know what the [ __ ] they're talking about
and I start yelling at my TV like a
goddamn maniac I'll tell what else
[ __ ] sucks that's right I'm on a roll
here about [ __ ] that sucks
[ __ ] I lived in New York like I'm so
[ __ ] sick of living in the city that
is the arch rival of the of one of my
teams you know and all day long I got a
look at these [ __ ] Laker flags
flapping off the side of the cars you
know those things a gay by the way you
drive down the streets with you flew
with your [ __ ] team Flags in the
window you seen those little clip on
things actually I see them and I start
getting angry you know what I mean like
it's a [ __ ] al Qaeda flag do they
have a flag you know what is what is it
of them sneaking into a pizza parlor
crouching in a cave
[ __ ] punks I just I see them and I
just want to [ __ ] you know I don't
know for some reason like like wire
cutters I don't know why you need wire
cutters to cut a plastic poor excuse for
a flagpole
I just want to snip him off what really
bill you take it to that level yeah yeah
I do
I don't do it but like I want to I want
to I would have gone to that Laker game
yesterday and I would have fantasized
about beating the [ __ ] out of everybody
in my row you know and the Celtics
winning by 40 it's not healthy it's not
[ __ ] healthy look at my leg my legs
[ __ ] shaking right now I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm doing here so yeah so
basically I lived in New York during the
height of the curse of the babe every
time I wanted to go see the Red Sox I
had to sit and [ __ ] Yankee Stadium
had people going 1918 you know and I got
that Catholic [ __ ] you know punish me
[ __ ] so I show up with my Red Sox [ __ ]
on you know and at that point we hadn't
won in 86 years so all I could do was
just personally attack the looks of the
person you know make fun out of their
hat look stupid on their head or some
[ __ ] like that and then they would be
like what does it have to do with
Championships nothing you [ __ ] idiot
we haven't won in 86 years I got nothing
here
all I can talk about is how you how
neatly your man tits sit on your [ __ ]
your beer belly fine I don't know so
then whatever the Red Sox finally win it
I can breathe you know what song is that
I can breathe again can breathe again
one of those [ __ ] 80 songs he thought
really meant something Dan oh no no no
[Music]
that [ __ ] was it I was a lot of reverb
reverb makes up for a lot that's like
the poor man's [ __ ] auto-tune
um anyways the [ __ ] am I talking about
here yes and then that [ __ ] ends you
know Celtics are dead in the [ __ ]
water then I technically not even a
[ __ ] NBA team when when I make the
decision to move out here and I move out
here you know one of the most
underhanded deals in the history of
sport Kevin McHale somehow decide we'll
give you our best player for nobody give
it back to our former [ __ ] team that
I used to play for and next thing you
know we're the [ __ ] and then I got a
sale takes out ba cheese and I gotta
listen to that [ __ ] these [ __ ]
flags I hate it I can't this business
being like you know Oregon this is how
much I [ __ ] hate like I'm sitting
there watching the game right and all of
a sudden I see Hilary Swank
you know courtside the worst courtside
in all of [ __ ] basketball is the
[ __ ] Lakers Jesus Christ those people
with their [ __ ] laminated faces this
is how [ __ ] [ __ ] up people are out
here in LA they get plastic surgery in
their 20s it's like you out of your mind
you that's to take a picture yourself in
your 20s when you get to your 50s then
hand them the picture and be like I want
to look like that you know giving
something to work off of give these guys
30 years to [ __ ] up other people's faces
before they get to yours Jesus Christ
you know stop eating fried food get on a
[ __ ] treadmill what's wrong with you
right I'm telling you become you know
game six
you know like I'm gonna be oh yeah if
there is a good six there's got to be a
game six this is gonna be a torturous
[ __ ] series I am worried about the
Celtics Garnett his heart and Paul
Pierce it hurt they're [ __ ] that Van
Gundy school yeah car Nets only going up
with one hand that's all I heard you
gotta use two hands for a rebound I hit
[ __ ] mute I'm like you think he
doesn't [ __ ] know that and my buddy
Paul virzi calls up he goes do it I
think Garnett's hurt he kept rubbing his
shoulder right and then all of a sudden
my buddy called me today goes yeah
they're saying that on the radio he
[ __ ] up his shoulder
see that's why I don't listen put it on
[ __ ] mute you know I don't like how
just all these [ __ ] people will now
act like like the same way the Lakers
won the first game then all of a sudden
of other Celtics [ __ ] finished right
and now the Celtics won out of the
Lakers food can be good do they play two
games it's one one it's a great [ __ ]
series so far okay it's the usual
[ __ ] thing they always gotta act like
whatever just happened is law for the
rest of the rest of [ __ ] time I can't
it drives me [ __ ] nuts but I gotta
tell you this dude io io Pau Gasol an
apology
alright now I'm not gonna be a dick here
and be like well you know Garnett isn't
[ __ ] 100% whatever that guy's going
strong to the [ __ ] hoop he is not the
guy he was two [ __ ] years ago that
guys playing [ __ ] great that [ __ ]
baseline reverse Jam he had was the [ __ ]
was this [ __ ] you see this this is a
Celtics fan given Pau Gasol props in the
middle of the [ __ ] series and I wish
more you [ __ ] sport [ __ ] could act
like that instead of [ __ ] you know
latch and you're hitching you if the
trailer of your loser life up to your
[ __ ] team to the point so you get so
into it that you can't even you can't
even appreciate it a [ __ ] good play
you know he's [ __ ] the Red Sox fans
who [ __ ] ever cheat of really really
[ __ ] stupid you know guys the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know when the best players
I've ever [ __ ] seen you know the way
he handles his [ __ ] on and off you know
do I want the guy to win [ __ ] no but am
I gonna sit here like an [ __ ] you
know and act like this dude isn't a
great player or that [ __ ] reverse Jam
Pau Gasol head was the [ __ ] I want to
know how Pau Gasol became a Laker
he's a [ __ ] up looking white dude if
that doesn't say Celtic I don't know
what does and this is really like the
classic Celtic Laker series where
they've always been just you know faster
always had more talent and we've always
just spent you know like this dis [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] [ __ ] up looking team
but somehow we win how many good looking
Celtics have there been I mean this
[Music]
Larry Bird Dennis Johnson Kevin McHale
Kevin McHale I guess had dreamy eyes if
you just focused on that but the rest of
his body good lord he looks like his
[ __ ] arms are so goddamn long he
looks like he would walk like that thing
in the and what was that movie with the
chick crawled up out of the well was
that the movie or was it that other
movie that the the oh Jesus Christ one
of those Japanese horror movies with
that [ __ ] thing crawls and as it
moves its hands its back legs would step
over its front [ __ ] legs like some
sort of mutant crab I don't know I don't
[ __ ] it Kendrick Perkins
I saw Kendrick Perkins by the way lobby
of this hotel about a week ago that guy
is a [ __ ] mountain of a man he's a
[ __ ] Mountain you know and to think
that he looks like medium-size next to
Shaq these [ __ ] people they you know
if you ever get down on yourself that
you never made you never made it to the
professional ever stand next to a
professional athlete and just realize
that it was game over by third grade
when this people walking around with
that sort of [ __ ] Bionic DNA Jesus
Christ I mean I can't believe I was
allowed to go to gym class pass the
[ __ ] sixth grade my pasty [ __ ]
Forrest Gump legs anyways so let's get
back to this [ __ ] man why the flat and
you know maybe maybe you guys can answer
me that why the [ __ ] do we care so much
like right now you know who's getting
their goddamn [ __ ] hearts ripped out
and our aging are the fans of the
Blackhawks and the Flyers all right this
is one of these great series where
somebody
is finally gonna have that anvil lifted
off their chest
Blackhawks haven't won since 61 the
Flyers have a1 since 75 okay
75 isn't as bad as 61 but you know what
the [ __ ] you know I was writing on my
Facebook page we pulled out of Vietnam
in 1975 all right there was only one
kind of Cheerios in 1975 you understand
I can't die Miami putting this in
historical perspective here and can i
dumb it down the Rubik's Cube was still
about six seven years away people the
last time the Flyers wanted okay
well buddy you just gotta [ __ ] dumb
everything down a friend of mine who
actually runs the the mmm podcast page
the the fan page the official and only
fan page of the Monday morning podcast
who he gets exclusive whatever you know
what I do is I do the podcast now cuz I
want it I want to take this podcast the
next level is what I do is I do the
podcast then III you know I upload it
and I send it to the dude who runs that
page and he puts all the [ __ ] you
know all the references up all the
YouTube videos and everything then we
try to sync it where we we both [ __ ]
put it on at the same time you know
taking it to the next level totally lost
just lost my [ __ ] train of thought
here oh that's right he sent me this
article this is the classic just dumb
and down just [ __ ] way that we're
running this country right now these
people actually I guess the nationwide
the National Spelling Bee is coming up
you know and everybody laughs at these
these kids who go up there they're right
at they're [ __ ] awkward years you
don't I mean where they have the nose of
the adult and like the [ __ ] teeth of
a [ __ ] two-year-old you know
twelve-year-old so they haven't a
National Spelling Bee in Washington DC
they celebrate these these Brainiac
[ __ ] kids that eventually will work
for a corporation and without really
knowing it will probably work on some
device that will someday kill millions
of people you know in other words the
future
hmm so there's people actually they're
picketing dispelling be all right I had
I had to [ __ ] read this to actually
believe it okay it says not all spellers
headed for Washington DC for the
National Spelling Bee spelling bee on
June 1st through the 3rd think English
spelling is a good thing that should be
celebrated with spectators and judges
inside the Grand Hyatt Hotel a while
while spectators and judges inside the
Grand Hyatt Hotel will be pondering the
spellings of obscure words and admiring
the efforts of contestants outside on
the streets some members of the American
Literacy Council and the simplified
spelling Society aka the SSS will be
trying to convince passerby x' that the
english spelling is a problem that needs
fixing why are people so [ __ ] dumb
okay now that's something if you want to
get support simplified spelling society
you don't go to the [ __ ] nationwide
Spelling Bee whether the kids just
learned how to spell [ __ ] rheumatoid
arthritis or whatever the [ __ ] they're
gonna ask him he is an effective your
grandmother has rheumatoid arthritis
okay that was mean isn't that two words
why wouldn't you just go to a bar you
want to get names on that [ __ ]
petition that's who you're doing it for
the dumb [ __ ] this is the point these
people have it said like those in size
side they may admire the efforts of the
contestants but they will have signs and
sandwich boards with slogans such as I'm
through with through in other words thr
you and thr ough I'm through with
through and enough is enough
spelt en you f e nu F and enough is too
much spelt en ough their aim is to alert
parents educators politicians business
people and others concerned about the
unacceptable level of illiteracy
illiteracy among English speakers to the
fact that a prime cause for this is
English spelling
do you get it the reason why there's
such a high level of illiteracy is not
because we constantly cut funding to the
public schools not because spelling is
something that's even [ __ ] stressed by
most people anymore it's because the
words are too difficult to spell one of
the Pickers pickers one of the picketers
this is hilarious and I can't even
[ __ ] read I'm part of the problem I
might sign these peoples petition one of
the picketers at the ALC chair in the
SSS member Allen mole from Boulder
Colorado put it this way our odds
spelling retains words like cough buh
through and though this increases
illiteracy and crime fix it and you fix
a host of problems we want to fix it -
this guy's basically saying that the
reason why there's serial killers
there's people holding up [ __ ]
McDonald's there's purse snatchers and
all this type of [ __ ] is because khat is
not spelled with a k you know I mean on
one side I [ __ ] respect this guy
because he actually has a cause he
actually got off his couch and said you
know what I'm gonna do something about
this this is the reverse of what I was
trying maybe that's why
let's get smart America bombed on my
podcast you know you guys are waiting
for this sss guy to come in here you
know i mean not not to be the classic
person who goes what's gonna happen next
but what is gonna happen next
2+2 was like four or five three you know
as long as you within one will give it
to you round it off to the nearest right
answer learn how to [ __ ] spell you
lazy [ __ ] that's pathetic
and i also like how to like the
illiteracy the illiteracy problem is you
know that's the reason why there's
[ __ ] crime you know I bet those [ __ ]
bankers you know those bankers are
literate and they're great at math
they're great at [ __ ] math where it
always works out for them the [ __ ]
[ __ ] they went to a [ __ ] Ivy League
school
why did I did I taper off a girl Eve's
schools Ivy League schools they went to
Ivy League [ __ ] schools they went to
brown
they went to Cornell Wentworth
I don't know that's one for you that
that dissing party [ __ ] you know
something that's you know what killed it
what killed it was was cable that's what
that's what really made people dumb
cable in the internet 800 [ __ ]
channels you know people used to back in
the day they used to load up a something
called a station wagon all right first
of all everybody had like five [ __ ]
kids back in the day all right which was
a great thing to do you know because you
know a couple of them are gonna be
fuck-ups okay and you can let it go you
can let it go
that's why parents who have only one kid
are so [ __ ] overprotective be
protective is because they went all in
World Series of Poker they pushed all
their chips and this is their one
[ __ ] hope that kid can't be a [ __ ]
serial killer
you have seven eight [ __ ] kids you
know one of them you know you can handle
it
you can [ __ ] handle it if one of
them's a phase the black sheep what are
you gonna do you know the [ __ ] you gonna
do I mean the guy he's a transvestite
and sometimes pyromaniac huh anybody
remember that line there he met a
transvestite and sometimes pyromaniac
the greatest line ever uttered on the
[ __ ] A&E Channel possibly in
television history when they were
talking about these DS this this serial
killer tandem that's how they described
one of the guys one of the guys was just
killing somebody on his own and then he
had to leave town because the heat was
getting too high and he went to a new
town hangs out in some shady bar and
that's where he meets his his his his
serial killer partner you know kind of
like when Bill Gates met that other
[ __ ] nerd and they made the first
laptop these two serial killers came
together and to describe his partner
that [ __ ] that Bill Curtis guy goes
there he made a transvestite
titin sometimes pyromaniac back in the
day people we had station wagons and
there was a whole bunch of [ __ ] kid
he didn't have to have a [ __ ]
spelling bee okay you have a spelling
bee because you only have one kid and
the kid can't compete against himself
you got to go with a bunch of other
[ __ ] kids back in the day we had two
station wagons and they were full of
[ __ ] kids alright and you just you
drove somewhere and on the way there you
know you listen to Mitch Miller Apple is
a rule room right and you [ __ ] you
said [ __ ] like do your parents would
quiz you what are Ivy League schools
name the capitals of sub states you know
that's what the [ __ ] you did and you
stopped in a rest area your dad sent you
in there by yourself there was no
problem there was no worries and you
walked in there and some guy exposes
himself to you it is not a deal with it
yeah just you buried it you got back in
the [ __ ] car next thing you know
you're at a Dairy Queen sort of enjoying
the ice cream but sort of not that's
when America was intelligent back when
we used to have like five six kids and
you throw them in a [ __ ] station
wagon and then you quizzed them as you
drove to some poor excuse for a tourist
attraction you know you go out to go
look at [ __ ] Wild Bill Cody's [ __ ]
log cabin you know your dad be sitting
there seething with anger left arm all
sunburned from heaven and hanging out
the side [ __ ] window the rest of him
ghost white and that was it
spelling test
and Dairy Queen somewhere along the line
it became oMG laughing my [ __ ] ass
off all this abbreviation these people
want to turn it into that [ __ ] that man
up you [ __ ] learn how to spell
goddamn words I did it for a month I'm a
better speller because it because of it
because it I'm not I've already forgot I
finally conquered the word restaurant
though forever I couldn't remember where
the you went its rest and then a you are
a NT I couldn't remember if the you came
which which a the you came after is it
restaurant or a restaurant
rest are aunt it's a restaurant these
[ __ ] people would spell it re st ra
NT restaurant no no that would still be
[ __ ] up how do you spell runt douche
you know that's rest rant how do I spell
that phonetically are est Ont no re st
ro NT restaurant let's go to the [ __ ]
restaurant I think I'm getting so worked
up like these guys are actually gonna
succeed you know it's like listening to
people down the south when they talk
about the South gonna rise again is it
are you gonna secede from the union how
did that work out the first time um Wow
look at me what what is wrong with me
alright let's get to some YouTube videos
for the [ __ ] week for the [ __ ]
week listen to me with my tough talk
alright hang on a second I got a couple
actually really good drum videos for you
guys to watch they're actually hilarious
somebody sent me this on my on my
Facebook and the name of this video is
this drummer search this this drummer is
at the wrong gig and it's just a guy
where he is [ __ ] it this guy is
awesome he is performing like it's still
and they are opening for like [ __ ]
motley crue and he is trying to blow
Tommy Lee off the stage that's the way
he is performing and they are they're
playing at like just some [ __ ]
banquet and everybody else has I'm
playing at a banquet energy and this
[ __ ] is just like I don't play
drums for [ __ ] years and I I would
have to slow the video down to try and
figure out how the [ __ ] he's doing some
of this [ __ ] he does this move with his
both his arms he looks like he's in a
dryer he the only way describe it his
[ __ ] coat is flying around and
somehow he never misses a beat it's
[ __ ] awesome but it looks absolutely
ridiculous yet awesome you just check it
out alright and you can watch all these
videos if you don't want to search okay
I'll make it easy for you just like the
sss people go to the the mm podcast.com
and we'll have all that [ __ ] up there
for you here's another one korean
drummer rocks out this is actually from
a long time ago but this guy is just
[ __ ] you know it's just what what
drumming and performing is all about
this guy he's the [ __ ] a lot of times
people arm the drummer I'm sitting
behind all these drums no-one's gonna
look at me this [ __ ] guy you can't not
look at him and they got this hot girl
singing the song you know and he's
[ __ ] he starts head-banging in these I
think this guy's like head banging
before people new out of head bang and
it's the last thing you can go on
YouTube and check out because I tried to
download this album it's the first
Aerosmith album which I haven't listened
to I think in about 15 years it's such a
great album it's the one that dreamin
was initially on that's only like the
really the real hit off and they usually
play like mama kin and stuff in concert
but they're that they're so [ __ ] the
album is so like raw and Steven Tyler's
voice he's he sounds so young and he's
just he's right at the beginning of like
a few of like his signature ways of like
phrasing and stuff and it's just a
[ __ ] killer album and my favorite
song on it is a song called moving out
by Aerosmith
and it's great that's just a production
of it and everything it's just so
[ __ ] like it just sound like they
scrape their last couple of [ __ ]
Dimes together and put it out and I'm
actually gonna go to a [ __ ] I'm gonna
go to am evil records today I'm gonna
[ __ ] buy that album because I tried
to download it on iTunes and they don't
have it isn't that a surprise isn't that
a [ __ ] surprise I don't know who to
blame on that one
is it Aerosmith cuz they're like well I
don't like the production of that or we
have you know our two hit songs are on
like 47 different every other
compilations I don't know what but I'm
right now I'm gonna put some money in
those [ __ ] pockets download that
whole album go out and buy it it's the
[ __ ] they've just a [ __ ] alright so
where are we at here 42 minutes in
almost 43 minutes and I got to cover
another [ __ ] seven minutes and then I
can [ __ ] can upload this [ __ ]
thing and get on with my goddamn day
here oh by the way I'm gonna be a
Caroline's comedy club this week with
Paul virzi opening up and in the middle
young Joe DeRosa the teen idol sensation
from the Opie and Anthony show I know a
lot of you out there read teen beats so
you're all up on Joe and his latest
hairstyle but for those of you not
familiar with Joe he has he has a
wonderful spread coming out in next next
month's teen beat anniversary issue
where he's you know he's he's swinging
on a tire you know shirtless laying in a
field
very very Keith Partridge Shaun Cassidy
sort of photoshoot you know it's done a
little bit ironic but you know there's a
lot of heart in it anyway see I'm gonna
be there what is it Thursday Friday
Saturday Thursday June 10th is my
birthday by the way okay so and I'm
gonna spend it on the road like some
lonely sailor no actually I don't even
know why I took the gig on my birthday I
know why I did cuz I owe the taxman
yeah the taxman
I don't know how you get rich in it and
I know why people [ __ ] steal from
people cuz that's the only way to get
over the hump every time I think I'm
gonna get over the hump of my mom on
[ __ ] Easy Street the [ __ ] goddamn
IRS shows up you know gives me the
[ __ ] right there Fred the right there
Fred to my [ __ ] nuts right there Fred
I just made my dog jumps sorry about
that dude sorry
right there Fred that was actually a
catchphrase of my family right there
Fred you know what that was it was
actually from a Flintstones episode
Flintstones episode where Fred was
trying to [ __ ] do you guys have had
that you ever just have a [ __ ] like
catchphrase and all your family gets you
know maybe you guys could send me into
those although I'll tell you one of ours
one of ours on our family was called
right there Fred yeah everything was
going great then the dude gives me the
[ __ ] right there Fred it was from the
Flintstones and Fred I don't he's doing
he was trying to impress Wilma that he
learned how to do magic and he has this
egg and he doesn't lean Oh a couple
little dupes he do's and he's like
alright well mo where is it you know and
he has his he has it like buried in his
fist and she goes right to Fred and she
[ __ ] pound it she pounded his fist and
broke the egg in his hand and exposed
him you know he thought he was the [ __ ]
and she made an absolute fool out of him
the proverbial yoke on your face but it
was in his hand so that became that
began enough that became the right there
Fred in my family anytime like you know
you think you went in an argument you
think yeah
it's anything funnier than watching a
big dog walk across hardwood floors I
swear to god you think that going across
a minefield Cleo what's wrong with you
huh you don't like walking across what
happened to you did you have a bad
experience all I have to say I don't
have to say like the entire you want to
go outside all I have to say as you want
and her ears come up Cleo you wanna go
inside let's see if I get her to howl
Cleo
no no down Cleo you want go as high
she's doing a little dip Cleo you want
to outside oh [ __ ] awesome is that
if you guys don't have dogs I don't know
why you don't have a dog and get a breed
that [ __ ] house I make it do that
every time that was actually just ah
it's just [ __ ] awesome um anyways
let's let's plow ahead what the hell was
it I was talking about catchphrases but
I was gonna tell you something else
I don't know oh speaking of my dog you
know what my [ __ ] landlord found out
I had it dug the you know my landlord is
listening to this podcast or the or the
old [ __ ] downstairs were added me out I
don't know what but I let it go I let it
go cuz you know make I have my coats I
have my own Oh name names and I don't
yell at old people alright I might talk
[ __ ] about him on my podcast
hey member that crazy lady that lady
that crazy lady that was telling you
about my neighborhood I was driving down
the street the other day and I just saw
her [ __ ] laying on the grass
screaming just fighting off like
invisible I don't know what and I
laughed like I haven't left and I don't
know how long it was so [ __ ] funny I
mean I feel bad for her and [ __ ] but
like you gotta understand like the
street I live on is a quiet Street and
I'm driving down this quiet street in my
hybrid which is actually even quieter my
hybrid the [ __ ] Bose headphones of
automobiles and it's just quiet you know
I got the windows down it's the perfect
day you don't need AC you don't need the
windows up it's just why you live in
California it's this [ __ ] awesome day
and you know [ __ ] blue sky
just a beautiful day I'm just cruising
down the street just got a bunch of [ __ ]
done I'm feeling good and all of sudden
I just I just you know as I'm coming up
on her I can't see her because this
car's parked on the side of the road I
just say this saw this faint like and
I'm like I you know it was so [ __ ]
bizarre is like what the [ __ ] is that
and then I just go
they ends up being like this just for
car gap between cars parked on the side
of the road I can't see this big SUV and
I want to come around the side of it
there's this crazy lady on her back like
a [ __ ] cockroach that can't get out
do you think just flailing in slow
motion I love Fred Sanford each limb one
at a time and it was just so [ __ ]
bizarre but she was so committed and she
was so into it and so just fighting
something off it was it was just Fu's
[ __ ] like it was so peaceful so
beautiful what a day and all of a sudden
I [ __ ] drove by and I just started
[ __ ] laughing it was it was just a
guilt-free laughs that was a guilt-free
laugh you know I didn't feel bad I feel
bad that she's out there but like I like
to think that I'm mature enough to know
that either way that's funny right I'm a
bad person
I probably am I don't know well that's
the podcast for this week everybody I
didn't get back to the way I didn't get
back to the Flyers I didn't get back to
you know I'm gonna talk right until my
phone call comes I got a phone call here
at 11:00 which is in four minutes was I
gonna say I [ __ ] getting back to the
Flyers and the the Blackhawks okay it's
a great series you guys really should
watch right now Blackhawks just went up
3-2 they are they are one game away flex
live it's a lot you know they always do
that well 28 minutes away from ending
the curse from ending basically 50 years
of frustration for these people okay
and you know to the fact that they have
like you know some of the original
players they have like five people left
from their [ __ ] team that aren't even
dead yet from the last time that they
played I'll tell you what's awesome is
Bobby hill Bobby Hall still looks like I
can't figure out if he looks like if
he'd still beat the [ __ ] out of you he
looks like the common he's in that weird
aging process where he still looks like
he could beat the [ __ ] out of you yet he
also looks like he signed the decorative
Declaration of Independence which would
have been hilarious if I didn't [ __ ]
stutter god damnit I'm dumb so I got to
be honest with you I'm gonna be happy
for either free the team it's gonna be a
shame that one of you guys have got to
lose and you know I'm looking forward to
more games
Celtics Lakers uh got respect for the
[ __ ] Lakers man they're a hell of a
squad and I was off I was really off I
gotta say it again I said Pau Gasol was
gonna get [ __ ] raped and the NBA
Finals and I'm most impressed with him
and Andrew Bynum said his name Andrew
I'm not a basketball guy I'm total
bandwagon here I'm a [ __ ] hockey guy
for years people have been saying what
the [ __ ] this guy's gonna do but he
keeps hurting his knees and it seems
like he's coming into his own and I
don't know man
it's gonna be tough at the Celtics beat
him it's gonna be really [ __ ]
impressive because I think they're
younger and they're quicker but we
always find a way we find a way to win
ugly that's what we do so we do what
about ray-ray reigning in those threes
you know and I had the whole game on
mute I probably missed a lot of the
excitement I listened to the crowd go
crazy but I think I don't give a [ __ ]
that's how I have to do it so I can
survive so there you have it that is the
podcast for this week coming uh come
check me out of caroline's this week in
New York City also next week I'm gonna
be at The Improv out here in Los Angeles
Los Angeles and I haven't put it up yet
but I haven't for years people have been
asking me to come out to San Diego and
I'm gonna be at the La Jolla comedy
store
the first weekend in August I don't have
the [ __ ] dates in front of me here
let me just chuck them up July August
the 6th and 7th I'm gonna be out there
so all you guys out there we've been
asking me to come down there I'm finally
coming down there hope you show up you
can check out my new hours [ __ ] and as
far as I know that might be right around
the time when I let it go my special
will be coming on Comedy Central then
you'll watch it maybe I call that
[ __ ] guy's hilarious I'm gonna come
down see him at the club and I'll hit
your over the head with the new [ __ ]
hour cuz that's how I do it
alright you [ __ ] now I'm talking [ __ ]
alright I'll see you guys next week have
a great week and get yourself a dog get
a big dog that tippy toes across the
[ __ ] hardwood floors you know how
awful you once a day it'll keep you
happy
[Music]
[Applause]
you break
[Music]
please
[Applause]
[Music]
you